kaden is with us in denver colorado good
afternoon kaden how can we help
hey how are you guys doing today thanks
for having me on oh man thank you
so i have uh roughly 120
000 in student loan debt i have
one that's about uh it's a consolidated
like 96 000 loan and then i have
two five thousand dollar loans and then
two uh just under four thousand dollar
loans
and i have the option to refinance my
uh largest 96 000 loan
to lower my monthly payment by 140 right
now
and i'm on snowball uh the snowballing
steps so baby step number two
okay and so i planned on refinancing to
get that 140 to put towards
my smaller loans okay um but on top of
that i'm currently putting in
8 into my 401k is that's what my company
matches okay
and i just didn't know if i should pull
that eight percent out
and put it towards my loans to help me
get out of debt faster
and i do have ten thousand dollars saved
in my savings as well
okay all right and so i was just looking
for some guidance and you know how to
maneuver and use what i have to you know
get those
rolling in the right direction you
called the right show man christy and i
are gonna walk you through this and help
you out as much as possible um so let's
let's
let's rewind uh talk to me about the
refi
uh two quick questions for you and you
may or may not know them if you do not
know these
what i want you to do is go and find out
here's the very first question
um is there a cost that whoever's
refining your student loans are they
charging you a fee
to do the processing to do it do you
know if they are
they are not okay cool so that's the
first step i like that number two
is the interest rate at least a good
full percent below
where you are now it's just under two
percent
just under i'm loving it i'm loving it
so yes we are refining
okay so what we're definitely gonna do
is gonna refi then i like how you said
it because we're going to take that
extra money that we got back and not
just the extra money
you got back which about 140 bucks we're
gonna go out there and we're gonna get a
job
okay we're gonna get an extra job and
we're gonna attack it so yes you're
gonna line up
uh your student loans from smallest to
largest now let me answer this question
so i'll make sure that we're teaching
the correct stuff do you have any other
debt
outside of your student loans right now
um i have no
credit card debt but i do have twenty
thousand dollars in a
loan payment an auto loan okay cool so
this is what we're going to do
walk this down so you're gonna put 4k
that's that's number one
you have two of those you're going to 4k
there 4k there then you have two 5k
you're going to line that up right
behind the 4ks then you're going to put
the 20k
in there okay then you're going to put
the 96k of student loans
so that's how you're going to line it up
so you're going to take that 96 uh
whatever you refi any extra money the
first one goes towards the first four
you can make minimum payments on all of
them but then you're going to do that
now you got ten thousand dollars you're
not you're not gonna like what i'm about
to say
all right but i'm gonna tell you how it
is because you called into the ramsey
show
and just on on this day you got christy
and anthony and so we keep it raw with
you
you're gonna take nine thousand dollars
of that
you're gonna knock out the both the four
thousand dollar loans
and you're gonna put a thousand of that
towards the 5k so now you're down
to 4k left and then 20 000 was your auto
loan did a 96 thousand dollars
then you're gonna aggressively attack it
so you follow what i'm saying
yes okay so you're gonna go ahead and
spend a 9k
on your debt you're going to stop
investing in eight percent
how much are you what does that come out
to for you how about
what 200 bucks that's uh 540 bucks extra
a month oh yeah
it could be getting yes yes yes stop it
right now as soon as you hang up from us
uh email hr tell them hey we need to
stop this we need to pause this
uh and don't pull nothing out of your
401k
okay all we want to do is pause we still
want the money to grow but we're going
to take that 540 plus the extra 140 and
we're going to put this towards your
debt
and if you aggressively do this man and
if you get an extra job on the side
you can definitely definitely get out of
this i was saying about two two and a
half years
um i'm gonna let chrissy talk to you but
then stay on the line i'm gonna have
kelly send you a copy of my
destroy your student loan debt uh book
that's free on christy and myself
actually free on me because this is my
my book chrissy's just shaking her head
thank you i appreciate that yeah yeah
read the book it'll take you an hour to
read it but
uh any other insight christy yeah here's
the thing i just want to call out
because it may be
tempting when you get into this caden to
uh list your debts from smallest to
largest just like anthony told you but
then you're going to have a thought
you're like wait a minute
wait a minute but what about the
interest rate shouldn't i attack
the highest interest rate first and
people start getting into the numbers
and they start getting into the math of
it and they start to try to well i
should do it different because my
situation is special
and i'm different and i got a different
set of baby steps let me tell you
something
if we were thinking about math we never
would have got ourselves into this
situation to begin with
this is more about motivation than math
and when you do what anthony just told
you to do and you knock out those small
debts it's going to give you a
burst of motivation and momentum and
progress
and you're going to get that much more
fired up you may go get two or three
jobs
to start to attack that next debt
because you can start to see the
progress of you knocking them out
and i just want to encourage you follow
the plan as we've laid it out
don't get distracted by the interest
rate numbers if that's a different order
for you
you want to stay focused on smallest to
largest because it's more about
motivation
than math i love it